you're gonna show everybody your tattoo
Antonina come on - see ya haven't done
the cooking video for a long time so
today I'm at this side - okay you know
haven't done it here so mommy if you do
one so if it sucks dude
stir-fry chicken guys with lettuce wrap
I'm gonna cut this in a half and then
just open it up a little bit
once you open it up try not to rip the
lettuce I'm sorry I forgot to tell you
one ingredient that you will need for
this dish
Oh Chris lettuce I'm gonna use that
celery sticks green onion I cut this
from my garden we're gonna use onion
mushrooms carrots and then chicken of
course you can use some chicken breast
chicken thighs my usefulness chicken
thighs so first I'm gonna watch the of
the lettuce and let it let the water dry
a little bit
you can use two Federation six bogging
down missing three and then one carrot
peel the skin I'm going to cut the
celery stick how I cut it is cut in half
it doesn't have to be too small it's a
boat of this size watch the fingers
carrot I'd like to cut the carrots in
three pieces first and they cut through
the middle
my fruit has ever really left mushrooms
I'm gonna put five mushrooms in you can
how you think the mushrooms you get a
towel wet with the water a little bit of
wipe you're done I take too long for me
so I'm just gonna wash it
doesn't have to be super small I'm gonna
put the onion with the mushroom because
I will stop that desert burning now
bring it
burning last things up because everybody
likes to like trouble as you guys know
I'm just gonna live a bit cilantro
laughing there are five chicken and ice
you can use to to trick impressive
enough so just cut it in like chicken
script
or if you want to cut it even in
slaughter your choice okay I'm gonna
watch this put the stuff away
sandwich okay so if you have you meet to
be tastier you can marinate the meat the
chicken the night before you can barely
with one teaspoon of stuff salt pepper
and soil stuff so you know sauce for our
say one tablespoon and an add little bit
oil the reason why you have for you
because when you stir fry it down when
you stir fry it it won't stick together
so did you just set some it's hot by
putting your hand on it the heat
tablespoon Nina's not always the
greatest at guessing the measurements if
we do a flashback to the salt Fiasco I
think that's something fun that the
audience would enjoy 1 teaspoon of me
to taste a little bit okay this freshman
but Evan doesn't like it cook at all
- he doesn't like it - that's so good if
you like not to cover just little cook I
will recommend you to a green pepper and
the red peppers do that gives the color
to the dish
all the chicken in the middle and Bret
the young the mushroom seller see their
eyes on the side so I can so that when
it's good I can put the chicken I just
had a flashback the stuff that you're
touching about it
the salsa let's show it one more time
one more time is up clip 1 TSP I'm just
gonna mix everything together right now
so still useable tablespoon because
we're gonna have soy sauce
you know what I'm expecting I will stick
to taste ground pepper 3 tbsp of soy
yourself
who's the flavour sauce you can get it
from a lot of the local supermarket
sells right now
two tbsp
turn the key not to stimbler so this
time I'm going to have a green onion and
the cilantro to give more to give it
more color and flavor to when you buy
that food you will taste all the
different flavor with onions and
cilantro
it's full and there are transferred to
the saturated awareness so it is do the
spoon put the chicken and you like to
wrap the chicken you can wrap it like
this
Hey
so positions then
Cheers
oh my gosh go what should I say thank
you for watching this video if you liked
the video please like and comment below
believe ah what do you want unit to make
next
leave a comment remember I have to eat
it so better be good no no spicy
no spicy okay thank you goodbye Jaime
Jaime shoulder shimmy